hello and welcome to the agenda a packed
week of committee meetings is in store
in Brussels next week crossing the world
with a dizzying range of issues from
transatlantic trade to relations with
Arab countries the fight against fraud
to country of origin labeling of
processed meat this last one is close to
Europeans who eat gigantic amounts of
bacon burgers and sausage but who more
and more want to know exactly where it's
coming from the more so after the
horsemeat scandal a vote takes place at
the Environment Committee on Wednesday
tea tip the transatlantic trade and
investment partnership is in the
spotlight also on Wednesday when the
international trade committee discusses
recommendations for commissioners
Cecilia Malstrom to take to the
negotiating table this for the first
time the results of a public
consultation on what's known as investor
state dispute resolution will also be
discussed many people in Europe fear the
mechanism will give corporations more
power than governments in disputes which
may affect their business the Secretary
General of the Arab League Nabil
al-arabi is due here for an exchange of
views on Tuesday coming almost two weeks
after the Charlie Hebdo attacks in Paris
it's likely to focus on among other
issues ways of combating extremism here
in Europe and in the Arab world another
topic on the button as far as today's
security concerns go how to finance
Europe's common security and defence
policy it comes after the new High
Representative for foreign affairs and
security policy federica mogherini
presented her priorities to Parliament
the Middle East Nigeria and Russia among
them Monday sees a debate on the EU
efforts to fight fraud and protect its
financial interests in 2013 1600
irregularities were reported as
fraudulent involving 309 million euros
of EU funds much takes place in the
distribution of EU cohesion and
your funds three students who took part
in a European youth event on the future
of Europe in 2013 of coming back to
discuss their conclusions and proposals
with mep s that's on tuesday and
thursday and make way for any of many
delegations from latvia which took over
the EU rotating presidency in january
and whose ministers will be swinging by
many committees to explain their targets
in the next six months all focused on
latvia is three big E's competitive
Europe digital Europe and engaged Europe
have a good